kristen
is with us in columbus ohio hi kristin
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i am a nurse practitioner and i am
currently
have a salary job that i really like but
i'm looking to go out on my own and
start my own business
on the side i'm trying to figure out how
much do i budget out of my personal
budget to start this up
i kind of have a general idea of what
i'm willing to just
like completely put in a blow category
if you will
too um and i don't i mean you can really
get down a rabbit hole with kind of
stuff like this and so i'm trying to be
sensible
about like setting a budget and what's
realistic but also
not shortchange myself too so i was just
wondering if you could help me figure
that out
the faster the business makes whatever
money you put into it back
the easier this decision is so
how much money are you talking about
putting into the business and how
quickly would it come back
with your estimate i mean you're
guessing but what are you thinking
um i i set kind of a base budget
to um like just five thousand dollars
just to
for startup costs and that's uh what
does that buy what do you need five
thousand
um that buys me basic equipment it buys
me no laptop it buys me some portable
equipment to do what business what
business is this
i'm a nurse practitioner and i want to
take primary care
like general health care into the
workplace
so i wouldn't need like a rental space
or anything like that for a brick and
mortar office
do you want a laptop i do but it's on
the
fritz and to support the electronic
medical record that i would need i need
to
get a new one okay all right and so
that's what a thousand bucks
right okay what else do you need i like
um a portable exam table um
and maybe and just some like blood
pressure cuffs otoscope
those different like supplies and stuff
like that
and how quickly would you make five
thousand dollars doing this
um i guess it depends on how quickly
well obviously but i mean if you do your
plan
and you work your butt off can you make
the five thousand dollars back in a
month or is it a year
uh oh um i would think
at least maybe first three months if it
starts if it's very slow to start
i would think within three months okay
and what is your current
income total uh i make just over 100
right now okay so we take five percent
of your income and we get it back in two
to three months
and then you don't keep buying crap
right now you make money right
don't call me tell me you need more
equipment you take that equipment and
you go make some money
okay and then then only after you get
this thing up to making 50 60 70 000 a
year do you start thinking about more
equipment or something
but um okay but you know that that's the
trap you get into that's the rabbit hole
you talked about the wormhole you can go
down
and uh the bunny trail whatever freaking
metaphor we want to use but
the uh but the idea being that just go
make money with the business and where
people get off track is they keep
thinking oh i need to grow my business i
need to grow my business yeah
only after you really really get things
moving do we worry about that
right now all we're trying to do is
change jobs the first goal is own your
job
after that the next goal is put more
stuff into it and own a business
okay so do you think five percent of my
income is reasonable yes
because we're going to recoup it we're
going to recoup it in two months
okay maybe three but i really want you
to do it in two
if it takes if it because here's the
thing let's if it drags out a year
you'd have been better off doing
something else right
and saving your money you know i mean
because five thousand dollars a year
i mean that's 480 bucks a month i mean
you can make that delivering pizza two
nights a week
you don't have to have a laptop you know
so
you know so don't you know don't get
that's that's the thing that people can
get all enamored with the dream of
owning their own business and that kind
of stuff so
but you're right on track you're doing
the right stuff hold on i'm gonna send
you a copy of christy wright's number
one best-selling book
the business boutique equipping women to
make money doing
what they love so there you go check it
out